You know what, I'm not even gonna comment on that.
So as listeners to Dear Hank and John will already know
I am a huge fan of the movie Rushmore
And within that movie there is a play set during the Vietnam War
in which a character is asked "How long you been in country?"
And the soldier replies,
"I ain't even here, Sergeant. I'm in Cheyenne, Wyoming."
Anyway, Cheyenne, Wyoming has since become my personal shorthand
for the place I visit when I am deeply immersed in a project.
Like, when we first started making Vlogbrothers back in 2007
I spent several months in Cheyenne because I wasn't really where ever I physically was
I was always thinking about what my next video was gonna be about
or how to grow our audience or about how cool YouTube was
But mostly I visit Cheyenne, Wyoming when I'm writing
Now, in a lot of ways being in Cheyenne is super fun
Like one of my primary complaints about human life is that we spend
the entire enterprise stuck inside of one particular slowly decaying body
and living inside of a made up world has always allowed me to feel free from that
Like free from the twin prisons from my consciousness and my body
But also for much of my life Cheyenne has been kind of an escape
like all those years when I didn't have many real friends and I felt intensely lonely
I could always go to Cheyenne where people would like me because, you know, I'd made the up.
That said when I'm in Cheyenne I'm also kind of, you know, like
not here, which means that sometimes I'll be at dinner with my kids and not answer when I'm asked a question
I neglect daily responsibilities, I forget to get haircuts.
I've been in Cheyenne, Wyoming for quite a while now and I expect to be here a while longer
And It can be really frustrating because I actually like my real life
And I like making videos every tuesday
and I'm not all the way here and I worry I should be
because the other thing about going to Cheyenne is that you aren't necessarily going to come home with anything
Like I spent about a year in Cheyenne finishing the Fault in our Stars
but I also spent several months there a few years ago only to realize that the book I'd worked so hard on
Wasn't very good  and wasn't gonna be published
For me at least I can't know until after I immerse myself in the work
Which is frustrating and scary but
You know what, actually, no "but" it's just frustrating and scary at the moment
Hank, in your video last week you talked about how to be productive
And I thought you gave very helpful and astute advice
But I think creative productivity is somewhat different
because for one thing you have to spend time in ways that markets and our culture don't really recognize as productive
Like reading or pacing or staring out the window
and then once you get deep enough into the work you have to make space in your life
and ask the people around you to to make space in their lives for you to go to Cheyenne, Wyoming
Now that doesn't mean working all day every day. I wrote my first two books at night after work
and wrote them quicker than I have any book since
but it does mean that a certain percentage of your intellectual and  emotional self will be absent for a while
then you make what you can of your time in Cheyenne, then, most importantly, you come home
to your body, to the sensate world, to the real people who you really love
Unless, you live in the real Cheyenne, Wyoming in which case the whole metaphor sort of falls apart
Anyway, Hank, that's as close as I can get at the moment to advice on how to make stuff
And I also want to say, I'm sorry if I haven't been around enough lately I will come home at some point
In the meantime, I miss you
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.
Endscreen! Hi, two things. First, over on my facebook page, I made a video sponsored by Google
about being internet kind in which I talk about my early life online way back in the 1990s
there's a link in the dooblydoo below
And secondly if you're going to be at vidcon in Anaheim in a couple of weeks
There is a nerdfighter gathering Thursday morning at 9:30
where Hank and I are gonna get to announce some exciting new Complexly projects
Very excited for it, hope to see you there! Thanks, bye